thierry amouroux porte parole du
syndicat national des professionnels
infirmiers
bonjour tirer amour merci d'être avec
nous sur l'alerté france edouard
philippe et olivier verront doivent
s'exprimer d'ici quelques instants
qu'est ce que vous attendez de la
conférence de presse du premier ministre
et du ministre de la santé
on attend les l'art et surtout l'arrivée
des masques sur le terrain parce que ça
fait des semaines qu'on nous dit ils
vont arriver demain ils vont arriver
demain donc là on aimerait bien que ça
se concrétise parce que pour l'instant
il ya un manque de deux masques de
matériel de protection à l'hôpital mais
également libéral clairement on rationne
vous avez deux masques par jour pour
chaque professionnel de santé qui
pensent en poste dans un chu
ça tombe à un masque par jour dont la
plupart des autres hôpitaux et pour ce
qui est des professionnels de santé
libéraux ils n'ont droit qu'à 18 masques
par semaine donc voyez qu'il ya un vrai
souci parce que du coup bas ont de se
contaminer de contaminer on devient
contaminants pour pour les autres
patients qui s'ils sont hospitalisés
sont par définition sont fragiles et me
risque de développer la forme grave de
la maladie
donc il ya une vraie responsabilité du
gouvernement le métier alors nos
confrères de france info annonce la
commande d'un milliard de masques à la
chine avec un pont aérien qui va être
mis en place avec cinq en six rotations
votre réaction
deux mois de retard c'est à dire que ben
c'est très bien que ça arrive enfin si
vraiment ça se concrétise
mais l'épidémie en a démarré en décembre
en chine et 2d fin décembre la chine
isolé 60 millions de personnes donc
las le simple principe de précaution un
simple bon sens voulait qu'on annonce
des commandes à titre de précaution dès
ce moment là et puis ensuite
quand c'est arrivé en italie
début février la là c'était plus du
principe de précaution c'était de
l'alerté rouge si c'était en italie
forcément ça allait arriver en france
donc il fallait commander en urgence des
masques mais aussi des tests et dans les
deux cas agnès buzyn est avant tout il a
fallu que enfin ils partent pour que fin
février le nouveau ministre prenne en
considération le manque de matériel ils
commencent à annoncer les commandes
donc on est heureux que ça commence
enfin à arriver mais on a perdu deux
mois stratégie que il ya une lourd de
responsabilités d'agnès bizarre et de
tous les hauts fonctionnaires juste
justement thierry amouroux parallèlement
cette information donc potentiellement
un milliard de masques qui devrait
arriver de la chine il ya cette
initiative du collectif ses 19 ans
référence aux comics 19 donc un
collectif de soignants composé de 90
personnes qui demandent la publication
des commandes des masques et qui exige
de rendre des tests publics à ce même
collectif qui a donc attaqué en justice
agnès buzyn et edouard philippe pour
négligence coupable
est-ce que vous soutenez ces initiatives
du collectif c 19 totalement il faut
savoir que pour l'instant on est
préoccupés par l'épidémie mais dès la
fin d'épidémie
il va y avoir des milliers de médecins
d'infirmières d'aides-soignantes qui
vaut déposé une plainte collective
devant la justice pénale afin que les
responsables politiques et les hauts
fonctionnaires du ministère assument
leur culpabilité en la matière parce que
s'il ya autant de morts en france c'est
en partie de leur faute
il ya eu un retard à l'allumage
l'idée est criminel de ne pas stocker
des masques ffp2 dans la réserve
stratégique de ne pas faire des
commandants ont tant donné
eh bien oui ils devront en répondre
devant la justice
est ce que cette
demande de preuves des commandes et les
dépistages de test parce que c'est une
signe de défiance totale vis-à-vis du
gouvernement total oui parce que l on
voit bien une incompétence un des
retards on voit bien que ya le problème
des masses comme il ya la même chose sur
sur les tests aujourd'hui en manque des
tests dans dans les hôpitaux on manque
de test dans les ehpad
donc nous avons des patients qui a
priori ont le profil qu'ovide et que
nous renvoyons chez eux si leur état
n'est pas trop grave faute de pouvoir
les tester et dans les ehpad c'est
encore pire parce que mon test dans un
ehpad de 2 100 ou 200 lits vous tester
un premier résidant à deuxième résidents
et puis nous avons consigne de ne pas
tester les suivants donc du coup on ne
sait pas parmi les résidents qui est
positif et qui est pour l'instant inde m
et donc les personnels qui sont sous
effectif et qui n'ont pas de matériel de
protection dont on dans la plupart des
ehpad est bien content mines l'ensemble
des résidents alors que si on pouvait
tester tous les résidents d'un ehpad
il pourrait y avoir du personnel réservé
pour ce qu'ils sont que vides et un
personnel réservé pour ceux qui ne le
sont pas de manière à limiter la
mortalité parce que malheureusement sur
cette tranche d'âge lorsqu'on est en
panne on l'a souvent plus de 80 ans
hélas le taux de mortalité n'est pas de
2 2% comme pour la majorité de la
population mais monta à 20% est donc là
encore ce sont des consignes totalement
inadapté et on voit bien la
responsabilité du gouvernement et des
arrêts récents nos métiers a justement
parlé du gouvernement mais quand le
président de la république a dit qu'il
faut mettre de côté
les clivages les polémiques pour faire
front commun qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez
ben nous nous sommes sûrs sur le terrain
au quotidien et c'est tous les jours que
l'on renvoie des passions chez eux on ne
pouvant pas les tester en leur disant on
va écouter
prenez du doliprane et puis le jour où
vous suffoquer vous appelez les secours
donc nous avons nous renvoyons donc des
gens dans leur foyers
oui ils peuvent contaminer leurs proches
et des gens qui pendant quinze jours
vont vivre dans l'angoissé
en dix ans peut-être que demain je vais
toucher
peut-être que demain je vais passer en
réanimation alors que si on avait pu les
tester et bien un petit écouvillon dans
dans le nez et 6 heures après on peut
leur dire ben monsieur vous avez gounod
money vous avez à gré où vous avez le
coc vide mais là on a quantité de gens
qui vivent dans l'incertitude et
l'angoissé pendant quinze jours et ça
c'est inadmissible
dans la cinquième puissance mondiale
qu'on me dise pas qu'on est incapable
dans une puissance industrielle comme la
nôtre de fabriquer des tests au fur et à
mesure des besoins de la population
vous avez l'islande qui a testé 100 % de
sa population
vous avez l'allemagne qui fait cinq cent
mille tests par semaine vous allez la
corée du sud qui a pu enrayer l'épidémie
grâce à des tests importants
elise événements des gens qui étaient
positifs
donc voilà l'énorme retard les énormes
erreurs stratégiques du du gouvernement
qui se traduisent par une développement
d'épidémies et des morts où on aurait pu
éviter
il a une nouvelle étude du professeur
raoul sur la chloroquine quelle est
votre position par rapport à
l'utilisation de cette molécule une
nouvelle étude qui a porté sur 80
passion dont 80% ont connu une évolution
favorable selon le scientifique français
et son équipe
je ne suis pas
un expert en la matière mais nous sur
sur le terrain on raisonne en terme de
bénéfice risque
pour ce qui est du pull du risque c'est
un le paquet ni les états médicaments
ans qui existe depuis 80 ans
comme tout médicament il a des effets
secondaires mais néanmoins lorsque vous
êtes hospitalisé dans un état grave
ben il n'y a pas de il ya un problème
les effets secondaires sont mineurs par
rapport à l'état général de de la
personne après sur l'efficacité du
produit en lui même il ya un débat
d'experts mais entre d'exo les messieurs
il ya aucun médicament ne peut rien
faire
et bah vous voulez que l'on vous donne
ce médicament on peut vous le donner
voilà la politique qui nous semble la
plus adaptée
dernière question ont tiré amoureux on a
parlé un des services hospitaliers
saturé dans certaines régions mais dans
le même temps il ya des cliniques
privées qui aimerait être plus sollicité
utilisés nous en fait le terme lancé
récemment par lamine guèye président de
la fédération de l'hospitalisation
privée
oui et encore on voit l'incompétence et
du du gouvernement et de toute la
technostructure des agences régionales
de santé dans les hôpitaux publics les
hôpitaux privés participant au service
public on ait eu des bordés et à côté de
ça et cliniques privées qui ont fait le
job qui ont déprogrammé quantité
d'intervention pour libérer des lits
afin de répondre aux besoins de la
nation sont très peu sollicité par par
les ars
et donc voilà on voit l'accumulation des
déserteurs de
la technostructure à à tous les niveaux
de même que nous nous avions demandé que
préventivement
on commence à envoyer des temps donné
que la vague est en train de monter en
ile-de-france à à pouvoir envoyer des
patients stabilisés qu'il soit kovy de
ou non dans les villes de l'ouest qui ne
sont pas encore atteints avant plusieurs
jours ou plusieurs semaines par par
l'épidémie de façon à pouvoir décharger
la pression sur sur l'île de france
parce que faut bien comprendre que au
niveau national n'avons que cinq mille
lits de réanimation
soit quatre fois moins que l'allemagne
et est donc il faut utiliser chaque lit
de réanimation au mieux et adapté et
pouvoir utiliser les lignes sont qui ne
sont pas encore sollicité dans les
régions qui ne sont pas encore atteints
par par l'épidémie et puis après lorsque
ça se ça va se tasser dans l'ès vous
voyez bien le décalage entre la vague
est arrivée sur mulhouse et la vague qui
arrive aujourd'hui sur sur paris et bien
il faut utiliser au maximum les
capacités on lit sur toute la france
merci merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions tir amoureux je rappelle que
vous êtes porte parole du syndicat
national des professionnels infirmiers